Many
women wonder what type of girls men are most
drawn to, the girly girl who always looks
as if she just walked out of a salon. The
business woman with a booming career. The
adventurous gal who will show you the definition
of a good time. How about the mysterious one
whom you're just dying to get to know. Psychological
studies showcase that there are four categories
of women that seem to bring out the best in
men. The femina, the islander, the regal and
the entrepreneur. All women contain a little
of each archetype within themselves with one
taking precedence over the others. 1: The
Femina. The Femina always looks as if she
has a daily stylist, she's fashionable, classy
and loves the finer things in life. She portrays
confidence, friendliness, vulnerability and
a sweet touch of femininity. Her irresistible
charm makes her easily desirable to men. Two
famous femina women are Princess Diana and
Halle Berry. Men are attracted to the femina
because she makes an effort to maintain and
showcase her style and beauty. They are visual
and they admire a woman who can externally
take care of herself. Better yet a femina
doesn't dress in accordance to win the approval
of men, but rather she does so to satisfy
herself. Bring out your femina by accentuating
your beautiful physical aspects gracefully
and modestly. Do you have great legs? Show
them off with a cute skirt. Do you have nice
shoulders? Wear a flattering top. The most
attractive quality is confidence, if you don't
have that level of confidence yet just fake
it until you make it. 2: The Islander. The
islander is energetic, comforting and lively.
No man will ever get bored of her, she can
easily win over the male heart with her smile
and natural charm. She's a non-conformist
and definitely a stand out of the crowd type
of girl. She rightfully owns her own unique
style just like Shakira and Nicky Minaj. Men
are attracted to the Islander because of her
spontaneous nature allows for her to keep
it interesting and constantly has men on their
toes. Channel your inner islander by being
adventurous, go do something you've always
been afraid to do but wanted to do anyway.
Such as rock climbing or diving. 3: The regal.
It takes a strong, confident man to be with
a regal. This woman tends to be highly selective,
reserved and well mannered. She is well aware
of what she desires and fully knows that she
will obtain it. Men find the regal attractive
because they like the array of mystery she
possesses and they enjoy the fact that she
isn't too easily available. When they finally
win her over, it's almost as if they've obtained
a diamond. Bring out your inner regal by simply
listening 80% of the time and talking only
20% of the time. Be sincerely interested and
ask questions when you truly listen to a man
you make him feel like he's important to you.
And you'll get a further glimpse into his
brain. Don't forget to add your own insight
and reveal some details of yourself as well.
4: The entrepreneur. The entrepreneur is a
career woman who wants to be a power couple
with her partner. She is intelligent, independent
and driven for success. She will easily override
passive-aggressive men and have no patience
for that. A man needs to be successful, dominant
and assertive in order to keep up with her.
Two famous entrepreneurs are Oprah Winfrey
and Hillary Clinton. The entrepreneur is attractive
to men because she's mentally stimulating
and can carry an educated conversation. She's
driven and continuously trying to improve.
Men of high social ranking look for women
who can keep up with them intellectually since
they enjoy discussing politics, philosophical
ideas, science, the news and such with their
partners. Channel your inner entrepreneur
by investing in self growth and improvement
whether that be to obtain a higher education,
grow your business or establish new connections.
Keep in mind that everyone has improvements
they can strive to work on, make a plan and
set out to follow it. Now that you know the
four main types of women, what type of woman
do you think you are? Or which types of women
are you most attracted to? Comment your answers
down below, if you enjoyed this video, be
sure to follow our Tumblr, Twitter and Facebook
for more content and don't forget to subscribe
thanks for watching and have a wonderful day.